[Música]
saludos en directo América de Francia 24
y me acompaña en el estudio más Romero
salamar bienvenida buena mañana de
viernes y hoy buscamos respuesta a una
pregunta que vamos a hacer a
continuación es posible desarrollar
vacunas contra el cáncer más buenos días
Raúl voy a empezar para decir que hay
muchos matices a esa respuesta entonces
pues vamos a irlos desglosando poco a
poco la primera cosa que queríamos
recordar es que ya hay vacunas que
existen contra el cáncer por ejemplo la
vacuna contra el virus del papiloma
humano que provoca cáncer de cuello
uterino no hace tiempo que se aplica y
un estudio del año pasado en Reino Unido
mostraba que había logrado reducir en un
87% los casos de cáncer de cuello
uterino también está la vacuna por
ejemplo contra el virus de la hepatitis
b un virus que puede causar varias
dolencias en el hígado pero que también
una de estas dolencias es el cáncer de
hígado no se administra de forma regular
desde hace tiempo en los esquemas
básicos de vacunación también tiene una
altísima efectividad Cuál es el secreto
Pues que son tipos de cáncer provocados
por agentes externos estamos hablando de
virus en este caso es mucho más fácil
combatir una gente externo que no unas
células cancerosas que se parecen mucho
a las células sanas que tienen muchas
similitudes y que son internas entonces
ahí está un poco la diferencia entre
estas vacunas de contra estos agentes
externos que ya existen en las vacunas
contra las células cancerosas entonces
mar En qué punto estamos en este momento
es desarrollar vacunas que si combatan
los tumores y las células cancerígenas
estamos en un lugar más optimista
claramente no hace unas décadas se creía
que era un objetivo totalmente
inasonible no una locura pero hoy en día
se tiene muchísimo más conocimiento
sobre el tipo de células que el tipo de
proteínas por ejemplo que hay alrededor
de los tumores no que antígenos tienen
Cómo se pueden combatir una de las ramas
digamos madre de las vacunas en la
investigación es la inmunoterapia que
consiste básicamente en todas esas
terapias que ayudan al sistema inmune a
combatir el cáncer de los pacientes y
dentro de esas posibilidades está
estimular el sistema inmune con una
vacuna que básicamente consiste en
enseñarle al cuerpo Cómo puede combatir
los tumores que se están desarrollando
no Esto está siendo investigado tanto en
vacunas de tratamiento personas que ya
han desarrollado el cáncer y que se les
ayuda a combatirlo de esta forma como
personas que todavía no lo han
desarrollado sobre todo en este caso
personas que tienen un riesgo puede ser
genético de desarrollar cáncer y que se
intenta prevenir que lleguen a
desarrollar Pues eso no células
cancerosas estamos Igualmente lejos de
las vacunas contra cáncers universales
es decir hay muchos tipos de cánceres
distintos cada persona además reacciona
de forma diferente y eso es lo que hace
que sea tan difícil entonces
probablemente estamos andando hacia
vacunas específicas contra tipos de
cánceres específicos también claro y
tenemos algún ejemplo de estos estudios
más resisten desarrollando hoy en día sí
vamos a hablar de uno que se que va a
empezar en breves de hecho su etapa
primera de investigación en los estudios
que van a hacer y es específicamente el
cáncer de colon está desarrollada por el
centro de cáncer MB Anderson de Houston
y su objetivo básicamente es frenar los
tumores antes de que aparezcan Cuál es
la estrategia de esta vacuna básicamente
es un virus que carga un ADN modificado
con 209 Neo antígenos los neoantígenos
son esas antígenos esas banderitas que
están alrededor de las células que se
encuentran en las células cancerosas
pero no en las células sanas que ahí
está como el cuit de la de la cuestión
no Entonces eso significa que el cuerpo
Pues aprende a reaccionar contra estos
ni antígenos y van a atacar a las
proteínas que se llaman aberrantes es
decir que pues son extrañas que no
deberían haber sucedido que son
cancerosas digamos y pues los primeros
pólipos No esas primeras pre tumores no
que se están formando entonces
básicamente busca que el sistema inmune
ataque estos pólipos antes de que se
desarrollen en tumores La idea es
administrar lo primero a pacientes con
síndrome de links que es un trastorno
genético hereditario que da muchas más
probabilidades de desarrollar cáncer
conectar aunque también de otros tipos y
luego si esto funciona bien se va a
administrar a centenares de pacientes se
van a observar durante 5 o 10 años para
ver pues así funciona o no por lo tanto
eso también nos indica que aunque haya
Esperanza Tenemos que tener paciencia
también paciencia amar la paciencia que
a veces agota no y desespera desespera
por supuesto pero en la ciencia es
indispensable Es indispensable y le
pregunto si se Está avanzando entonces
hablando de ciencia en estas vacunas de
ARN mensajero es muy sonadas También en
esta pandemia de 19 creo que tú vas
aprendimos un poco sobre eso Por
supuesto Y qué bien que aprendimos no es
una de las grandes ventajas que hemos
tenido en la pandemia y más con estas
protagonistas que han sido las vacunas
de ARN Mensajero de hecho Vaya un teki
moderna que son las que desarrollaron
este tipo de fármacos llevaban tiempo
desarrollando investigando en vacunas
contra el cáncer de mensajero por eso
también fue tan rápido desarrollar una
vacuna contra el 19 porque ya tenían
Toda esta experiencia y también se
espera que a raíz de la pandemia se dé
un poquito más de gasolina a esta
investigación porque ahora pues estas
las vacunas que se desarrollaron con
esta tecnología se han administrado a
millones de personas ha visto que es
eficaz se ha visto que es seguro por lo
tanto pues tiene muchas ventajas ya a su
favor la gracia además de este tipo de
tecnología es que es muy flexible
permite jugar mucho con el que le pones
que le quitas no que proteínas le haces
desarrollar y cuáles no y por eso se
está usando y se está investigando en
terapias personalizadas es decir una
persona desarrolla un cáncer se recogen
muestras del tumor y del tejido
canceroso y así se le desarrolla se le
desarrolla particularmente una terapia
contra sus proteínas sus antígenos que
desarrolla el cáncer pero vamos
simplemente a decir muy rápidamente ya
cómo funciona no básicamente escoger
parte de material genético que produce
una serie de proteínas que se encuentran
eso como decíamos alrededor de los
tumores y cuando entran en contacto con
el organismo sobre todo son las células
dendríticas que son como Los Centinelas
del sistema inmune que la reconocen
luego estas van a enseñárselas a las
células t como decir mira Esto es lo que
hemos aprendido Esto es lo que tienes
que compartir y estas células t son muy
importantes porque son las que combaten
luego las células cancerosas y así se
despierta digamos de esta respuesta
inmune contra el cáncer Entonces ya para
concluir volviendo a tu primera pregunta
probablemente es posible probablemente
va a pasar algo de tiempo veremos Cómo
se desarrolla Pero hay motivos para ser
optimistas y desarrollar nuestra
paciencia no Mientras esperamos esta
buena noticia Así es mar como siempre
Muchísimas gracias por toda la
información buen fin de semana el lunes
volvemos por supuesto con más salud aquí
en directo América con más salud